as long we go further to the city of
private which is quite dirty
in this case you hear that sound because
level of the radiation increase all the
time
deep in chernobyl's exclusion zone still
steeped in radiation the ghost town of
pripyat
frozen in time a time when russia ran
ukraine a time russia's current leader
seems to yearn for now
it is deadly quiet and eerie left as it
was when it was evacuated 36 years ago
the order to empty chernobyl's vast
exclusion zone came from moscow there
are now fears russia is about to send
troops through here on the way to kiev
there's nothing for an invading army
worth taking
except for the shortest route to the
ukrainian capital
if they chose it it would take russian
forces past what was once the most
dangerous place in the world
now made so safe you can come within a
few hundred yards
apart from the reactor now capped under
this massive metal and concrete
sarcophagus and the deserted town of
pripyat the chernobyl exclusion zone is
open empty countryside perfect for
russian tanks to sweep through from
belarus to kiev
north of here in belarus tens of
thousands of russian troops have been on
maneuvers we joined the ukrainian border
guard on patrol inside the exclusion
zone in the light of the russian threat
they've stepped up their deployments
on
but also in the place they're patrolling
equipped with radiation monitors
they'd be ukraine's first line of
defense if russia does use this
wasteland as a back door to invade and
launch a lightning advance south on kiev
dominic waghorn sky news in the
chernobyl exclusion zone